[Music]
after 14 long years Incredibles 2 was
finally released and it wouldn't be a
Pixar film without some hidden secrets
stay tuned to find out the biggest
secret you probably missed can't get
enough of Pixar in your life then
subscribe to the things for more awesome
videos now let's get to the 10 secrets
you totally missed in Incredibles 2
animal inspiration animators get their
inspiration from lots of things but in
Incredibles 2/3 of the new characters
were inspired by creatures from the
animal kingdom
remember reflux he's one of the best new
additions to the Super's he's an old man
who can vomit lava and that's more than
a little gross
animators struggled to find a way to
draw reflux without totally grossing out
the audience so they decided to use a
frog as their model we totally see the
Frog like appearance now another new
character with animal-like design is
billionaire Winston Dever he's the guy
who hires Elastigirl to help give supers
a better image he's smooth he's driven
he's fierce he's a shark that's right
his design is based on a shark you can
see it in his sharp like features skin
like forehead and even his shark skin
suit his sister Evelyn is based on a
land dwelling animal she's a cat she
looks approachable and laid-back but
she's really quite calculating and
confident it turns out that she is the
screen slaver the villain that
hypnotizes people by hacking their
screens we totally understand now how
she's a cat they always say they look
like they're plotting something
character changes a lot has changed
since 2004 an animation technology has
definitely improved if you didn't watch
the two incredible movies back-to-back
you probably didn't notice the subtle
changes not only is Bob better known as
mr. incredible more worn out as a
stay-at-home dad he's also put on some
weight his outfits were deliberate too
as he gets more tired and burnt out his
clothing gets more drab Edna mode
everyone's favorite superhero fashion
designer looks stunning in her kimono
instead of her black business outfit
from the first movie as far as the
animation difference
she has a bit of around her nose even
though the film picks up immediately
after the first movie Elastigirl
appears to have grown out her hair a
little may be fighting the Underminer
has that effect she's not the only one
with a different hairstyle - seems to
have found some volumizer his hair is a
lot taller - is another major change a
new voice actor since it's been 14 years
they needed a new kid - voice' Frozone
has a pretty major update - he's been
working on his abs and now has a
six-pack that wasn't there before but in
the age of Marvel and DC cinematic
universes we kind of expect our
superheroes to look like pros own Pixar
Easter eggs every Pixar movie has
special references and uniting details
one of the biggest references is the
number a 1 1 3 it appears throughout
every Pixar movie a 1 1 3 is the
classroom where Pixar's biggest name
animators studied at the California
Institute of Arts in Incredibles 2 we
see a 1 1 3 several times we see it on
the sign at the movies when violet goes
on a date there's an office at Dove tech
with the number and we also see it on
the front of a train where else does it
hide and Pixar films in cars a 1 1 3 as
mater's license plate in monsters
university it's an actual classroom and
in the first Incredibles movie it's the
cell where Syndrome keeps the rocket
when the power family gets Chinese
takeout they go to the same restaurant
that's in ratatouille monsters ink
inside out a bug's life and Toy Story 2
we wonder if the animators order a lot
of Chinese food when they're working
late nights on these awesome movies who
is hungry another nod to the Toy Story
franchise is the appearance of a planet
pizza truck
the last big Pixar Easter Egg is the
luxo ball from the Pixar movie opening
it appears as a ball and we also see a
picture of the ball in Jack Jack's
nursery common core joke bob has a lot
of frustration when he becomes a
stay-at-home dad it's pretty relatable
for the parents watching being a
full-time parent is no easy job at one
point in the movie bob is helping - with
his math homework when bob was a kid he
learned math one way but - is trying to
show him the way they were taught it's
totally different Bob gets so mad math
his math math is math he yells this -
sounded familiar to both kids and adults
how many parents get frustrated at the
changes to math when they help their
kids if your parents were laughing in
this scene it's because this was a joke
about common core math common core is a
set of educational standards that almost
every state in the United States uses
the idea was to make sure every kid in
the country was learning all the same
things in the same way while Common Core
gets a lot of criticism lots of teachers
hate it and a lot of parents don't like
it either Common Core change the way
basic math is done it doesn't always
make sense to adults and it's hard to
learn a new method this joke is
definitely meant to appeal to the
parents who get frustrated at homework
time tribute to bud lucky the next thing
you missed isn't quite as funny as some
of the jokes but it's super sweet
there's a tribute in the credits to bud
lucky he played Rick dicker the guy over
the superhero relocation program in the
original Incredibles movie but sadly he
passed away
earlier in 2018 he was an amazing 83
years old and he passed away from
natural causes
but he's not just an actor from the
first movie he's a Pixar pioneer but
lucky was one of the first animators to
join Pixar he was an Academy Award
nominated animator he had voice acting
experience too he helped design some of
the most iconic characters ever Woody
from Toy Story was designed by lucky he
also worked on Finding Nemo a bug's life
cars and more if his voice in the
original movie sounds familiar you might
have heard him voice or in the 2011 we
need the Pooh movie he also voiced
chuckles the clown in Toy Story 3 way
back in the 1970s but lucky even worked
on Sesame Street
lucky is a total legacy in the world of
children's entertainment and appreciated
by generations we're so sad that he has
left us but we know his legacy will last
a long long time recording studio secret
the voice actors in Incredibles 2 are
amazing they have such great chemistry
together
you probably think they were all in the
recording studio together right wrong
Polly hunter who voices Elastigirl
revealed the secret in an interview each
voice actor was only in the studio with
a director Brad Bird bird would play the
parts of all the other characters
and give individual directions to the
actors he would describe the scenes to
each voice star and they could see the
storyboard Holly Hunter said she didn't
even have a script in front of her Wow
Bradford must have been really great at
describing the scenes to the actors he
totally had a vision in his head and was
able to put it together from individual
recordings and this just goes to show
how great all the actors are they didn't
even have each other to play off of or
know all the parts Matt takes some
seriously talented acting and directing
which just makes us appreciate the
awesome cinematic masterpiece even more
if you think that's a huge secret wait
till you hear the biggest thing bird
tried to spy you top secret theme songs
in Incredibles to businessman Winston
Dever wants to improve the image of
supers through stage acts of heroism to
prove he's really a fan he sings a few
bars of their theme songs Elastigirl is
totally not feeling it the scene doesn't
last long but it does leave us wondering
what are these top secret theme songs
well if you stay through the end credits
you can hear the full versions of the
theme songs for Elastigirl
mr. incredible and Frozone the songs
have a very retro feel like the costumes
in the scenery in the movie the composer
Michael Giacchino gave songwriter Alex
Lakha more free range to write these
three theme songs lack a more superpower
is definitely songwriting ever heard of
a little musical called Hamilton Oh Mia
he worked on that with V lin-manuel
Miranda and he also worked on the
amazing soundtrack from the greatest
showman the songs are simple yet catchy
and they really add to the classic
superhero vibe here comes Elastigirl
tells us nothing is out of our reach
literally and figuratively chill or be
chilled is just as cool as Frozone and
pow pow pow shows us just how tough mr.
incredible really is not that we've
listened to them a million times or
anything don't judge okay maybe we have
died negai statue
Winston Dever loves superheroes
seriously we're pretty sure no one loves
superheroes more than him except maybe
his father he mentions how his father
had a giant statue of Dyna guy built but
it's
as random as it may seem it's a
throwback to the first film remember
Edna modes one rule about superhero
costumes that's right no capes capes are
totally unnecessary and they get in the
way we learned in the first film that
it's Dyna guys cape that ultimately
leads to his demise in a freak superhero
accident this is what like Edna to form
her know Kate's rule Winston Devers
mention of the statue serves a few
purposes in the second film first it
shows how he got his father's love of
superheroes and gives him some
credibility it also serves as an easter
egg from the first film to tie the two
together the diner guy statue also
serves as a tribute to the life of a
great super as well as a warning to
other supers not to meet a familiar fate
listen to Edna and don't wear capes
who knew one little line and one giant
statue could mean so much to the movie
Batman although we don't know exactly
when Incredibles 2 takes place it has a
very retro 1960s feel and in the 1960s
Batman was a popular TV show
there are many Batman references
throughout the Pixar movie - says his
powers define him and that he heard that
phrase on a TV show this is a nod to a
line from the original Batman TV show
and if The Incredibles takes place in
the 60s it makes sense the - would be
watching Batman mr. incredible has the
incredible a car reminiscent of the
Batmobile when it goes in the water
there's even an original Batman sound
effect if you look closely you can see a
bat signal in the sky near dev tech the
putty is Batman references more modern
Elastigirl takes a look at her new
costume she describes it as dark and
angsty this is a jab at the dark vibe of
both the latest DCU movies and the
Christian Bale Batman movies we love how
deep the Batman references run in the
new movie as such a classic superhero
it's only fair that Batman is given a
fitting homage in a movie about
balancing powers with normal life
the next return of the Underminer
director Brad Bird is not a guy who
makes a lot of sequels let alone three
equals that explains why there were
fourteen years between the first and
second incredible movies but if you look
carefully at the end credits
you might see a possible hint of a third
movie at the end of the first movie the
Underminer
appears and the movie ends on a
cliffhanger the second movie starts
immediately after the first movie ended
the incredible family must fight under
miner but he escapes in the end credits
we can see under miners drill coming up
from the surface is this a hint at a
third movie we don't know but we sure
hope so the actor who plays under miner
is an easter egg of his own john
ratzenberger voiced ham in Toy Story and
has appeared in every Pixar film since
he also played Mack in cars the teacher
of the fish school and Finding Nemo and
Yeti in the Monsters Inc franchise he's
considered Pixar's good-luck charm do
you think we'll see Underminer again
will there be a third Incredibles movie
don't be shy let us know in the comments
and those are the 10 secrets you totally
missed in Incredibles - hey check out
our community page and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]